Being in that environment
in such close proximity
to the virus, there's just
a point at which everything
around you, your clothing,
even your own skin,
begins to feel a
little bit sinister.
My name is Nichole Sobecki.
I'm a photographer.
And I was recently on assignment
for National Geographic
in the Democratic
Republic of Congo.
[haunting music]
Since August, the
Democratic Republic of Congo
has been facing the
worst Ebola epidemic
in the history of the country.
It's also the second
worst Ebola epidemic
in the history of the world.
And it's all happening
in an active war zone.
You also have a tremendous
amount of distrust
from the community
that's being treated.
There were several
Ebola treatment centers
that were attacked in Butembo,
which is the epicenter
of the crisis at the time.
Since then, there have
been more attacks.
There have been police officers
killed, health workers killed.
And the reason why people
don't trust health workers
is for reasons that I
find incredibly rational.
They don't trust the
government because this
is a part of the country that
has been neglected for decades.
And that's leading
to people, you
know, not wanting to be
tested, avoiding treatment,
not following safe
practices around burials.
And it's making it incredibly
difficult to contain the virus.
I think it took actually
being there on the ground
to really understand the
emotional component of that
as well.
The fear that anything
could infect you is there.
And it's not rational.
And I know that.
It helped me to understand
how these falsehoods could
lead to really real violence.
[haunting music]
I want people to care
about what's happening
and to not see
Ebola as something
that only happens far, far
away in parts of Africa
and has no impact
on their lives.
These are not rural
villages in the way
that we've seen in
other outbreaks.
Beni and Butembo are cities
of more than a million people.
This is a global
issue that I think
we should all be invested in.
[haunting music]